a rose is a rose and a nose as a nose
except when it falls under the skilled
hands of the makeup artists not only
roses but entire faces bodies and hands
are transformed through the use of molds
prosthetics wigs appliances and most of
all a creative eye and a vivid
imagination the nominees for makeup are
Michelle Burke and Jean Pierre fashion
for Cyrano de Bergerac
John coglioni jr. and Doug Drexler for
Dick Tracy V Neil and Stan Winston for
Edward Scissorhands
and the Oscar goes to John coglioni jr.
and Doug Drexler for Dick Tracy
she's what we'll have to thank God we'd
like to thank the members of the Academy
Dick Tracy was a character makeup artist
dream come true
Thank You Warren Beatty for taking a
chance on two guys from Brooklyn Melina
cannon arrow who never let warrant
forget that we were out there Vittorio
for his wonderful cinematography and
dick silver for as an erring artistic
support the actors who suffered
countless applications of glue and
rubber the talented makeup artists a
wonderful lab crew thank you we'd also
like to thank Barry Osborne Thank You
Jon Landau our guardian angel Jeffrey
Katzenberg all the good folks at Disney
and touched on Chester Gould and the
Gould family and especially our own
families
Jay Allen my wife Donna who stood by us
through thick and thin thank you
incredible thank you thank you